super early Sunday morning
no one's awake yet it's pretty rare to
get quiet time in this house there's
always something going on so I have to
take these quiet moments while I can
they're rare and few and far between
early in the mornings the best part of
the day
the GoPro battery died it's probably for
the best
this way I can wipe the slate clean
table Raza and start over because if
you've been following me on YouTube for
some time then you know that back in
January I made this promise to you guys
that I was going to deliver one video
every single week have a look the goal
part of this for me
is that I'm going to be putting up a
minimum of one video per week every week
for 2016 that's the that's the goal that
I set for myself and I'm nervous I'm
like scared about it I'm intimidated
yeah that didn't really work out did it
I think it's been about eight weeks
since my last video that puts me eight
videos behind on my promise so I suppose
you can say that I failed and I've been
thinking a lot about why I stopped
making videos after making this pledge
and I've come to the conclusion that
there are a couple reasons the first is
that to my detriment I tend to be a
little bit of a perfectionist I want
every single piece of content that I put
up online to be the best the most
polished the most helpful that it
possibly can be and what happened is
that in the course of making videos I
ended up spending ridiculous amounts of
time editing these things I think like
eight hours on average per video and I
just burned out also and much more
importantly I think when I look back at
the videos that I did put up over the
course of 2016 I can't help but feel
like they're little forced
perhaps some what effect
ed slightly derivative I suppose and I
feel like actually needed to stop making
videos to take a beat and think and
ponder and meditate on what it is I
really want to do and say here what is
it that I want to express not how can I
look cool and make a super fun groovy
video but how can I put out content that
is truly authentic to Who I am
helpful and most of all representative
of me in the most real sense possible so
after this period of reflection I've
decided that I'm going to take a stab at
vlogging and I feel like in certain
respects this might be the best way for
me to convey my ideas and do it in a
genuine real and less effective way I'm
not making any promises about how
consistently or frequently I'm going to
do this and these videos are going to be
much rougher much less polished than
some of the other content that I've put
out because I just can't afford to be
spending several hours every single day
editing especially if I want to achieve
some level of consistencies if I am
going to do this it has to work within
the construct of my life which is super
busy juggling lots of different things
right now but I'm going to give it a
shot all right it's late Sunday
afternoon which for me means one thing
time to go to work
veggie sushi
Sunday afternoons and evenings are
always very busy work times for me
because this is the time when I produce
and put out the podcast and tonight I'm
working on the episode with Arianna
Huffington that will post late tonight
one of the most challenging things about
doing the podcast every week is trying
to write a really engaging blog post
that accompanies the audio format of the
interview I probably spend way too much
time on these blog posts but they're
important to me their creative outlet
for me and I feel a sense of pride when
I write something great and interesting
and unique to me about each week's guest
so that's what I'm here to do so time to
get to work
alright the pot house is done I'm pretty
happy with it here I'll show you here's
what it looks like it's all about sleep
here's my blog post or TED talk getting
enough sleep doesn't mean that you're
giving up your goals or your desire to
achieve and succeed on the contrary it
makes you more effective it's a
performance enhancer all right so the
podcast with Arianna is done I'll put a
link up wherever those things go so you
guys can check it out and read my blog
post and normally that would mean that
I'm done for the evening and I can go
home but I guess I got to edit this
video now right so I'm going to call it
a night this is the end of episode one
of the vlog and I will see you guys
tomorrow hopefully maybe no promises